oh why are we you know [ __ ] I played
this map yeah yeah I
far too often wax around wait help me
give me a prop you know where I am
he's outside in this shed I bet wait
wait wait I don't actually know where
you are
oh [ __ ]
this map had my favorite episode from it
super baby I love that what I don't know
about the thing I don't know if I know
exactly what thing waits talking about
but I have an idea if there's a glitch
where you can get to a place you can't
normally go oh I don't know about that
okay I don't remember how to do it but I
have a guess but I don't know I'm in a
perfectly reasonable place right here
really yeah all you have to yeah I don't
know how it works we come let's kill a
jack let's go I was like the most
vicious you've ever sounded Bob I'm
gonna murder you okay I'm just trying to
scare you they're working he's scared
I'm very scared it's working Bob I think
you're onto something there jack really
okay maybe not risky on all the things
yeah do that that'll help you alright
work this Jack ring it really [ __ ] you
open this door no they're in here
they may have come out behind us and are
hiding amongst the cars you got your
peepers mmm I'm about to pee right all
you have to do is dodge until they kill
themselves you're good you're solid weed
you're in a great spot oh you're
beautiful you're a shining star yeah
that doesn't sound like Wade yeah but I
have to say these are my team okay then
yeah mmm wait to star well Bob are you
afraid to hit anything cuz you think
you'll die oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
pretty pretty afraid all right so the
bathroom door was also open I'm gonna
bet weight is outside that sounds right
I'm fully willing to wait wait why wait
you were so perfect
you're such an idiot why do you change
did you close this door when we came out
you know yeah damn it it was perfect
before you ruined it I think he's gotta
be a bleach drug even lunch room maybe
no I was a bleached jug first you you
were spun gravity damn it Oh
he almost managed either just stayed the
lamp god is so boring
okay we're doing the moving are we doing
that we need to move rule I mean it's
more exciting that way we need to move
like a douchebag move around okay well
[Laughter]
maybe the chair no no no you made the
right choice thank you thanks jack well
if I can become this enormous thing
myself
[Music]
hey he's one of the cars I bet No
why why would I make the same mistake
twice yeah Cheers it's a very good
question wait I didn't screw up right
did I no you did good you you did good
[Laughter]
oh hey I see some stuff going on what is
the bottom one
[Music]
[Laughter]
my stupid name thing popped up on the
bottom one my trusting Bob anymore
I'm on my own Jackie's that lamp is
standing oh wow I've never given away a
hit like that huh Jack I don't think you
are where you want to be no I no I don't
think so either
I don't think you're talking to Jack Oh
is there a jacket oh yeah I think I mean
I didn't hurt to shoot it you know the
one that's facing the wrong way stuck in
the wall I don't know shake oh there you
go there he go where he cool be cool be
cool be cool be cool be cool yeah be
cool I got this Bob yeah me hard for
warrior yeah you're good you're good
right now fist bump the camera was gonna
open in on that Thanks thanks for the
warning no that's usually my line yep no
is he Oh Robin and Weavin okay yeah
that's my spot great well if you just
move your right a little bit yeah
perfect okay cool cool cool cool yeah
thanks I don't know how that helped me
at all but okay you're much better now
am i I'll believe you because I know
that I'm not the same way I think I am
guys don't know I'm own natural
it's friend it's it means email season
baby L it's French oh he's a washing
machine thing yes
that's suicide pill Jack are you dead no
that's that's been there or the whole
time that was awesome thank you I know
do not all great didn't they do it
better than Bob did right right yeah I'm
laughing at all the people watching and
laughing I'm laughing right well this is
happenin all right
see Bob that's my plate I keep wanting
to do things correctly just doesn't
happen idea and I almost executed it
correctly if it's any consolation I
stuck to fact there's only two garbage
cans outside there was a I don't think
that's the proper name the whole they
didn't see if they didn't see it I do
too so bad right there was just pushing
around [ __ ] in the bedroom room you over
the door and I peeled the hell out of
there man he was gone okay wait there's
no this perhaps not that big though I
don't know where to go
wait don't trust him easel
yeah I know is that iron oh wait a
minute
what well some a right here what are you
I see Bob's name that's weird what I see
happening right I'm invincible
I'm not losing any damage you were you
the desk I was the dad time you were
there for a long time and push it around
push it around I thought it moved and I
thought it was of you I did you push me
around you push them into the wall okay
he was pushed on me he was pushing on me
I had a drink my hand
[Music]
the smallest jump ever and